5 15 on your Friday morning was cool at
school how about some well-deserved
recognition for whip smart high school
students who not only learn the finer
points of our constitution they also
have to prove that they know what
they're talking about
I joined the video people to get a
further extensive knowledge on our
government Brian Lee just one of the
Southwest Career and Technical Academy
students recently featured on the Clark
County School District's student
Spotlight show on Vegas PBS teacher
Joseph Giuliano coaches the school's
team what the students are doing is
preparing for a congressional hearing
they study case law on specific parts of
the Constitution make presentations and
answer tough questions from judges who
in some cases are actual judges from our
local courts the local sponsor of the
program the Nevada Center for civic
engagement executive director Kathleen
Dickinson University professors tell us
that students who participate in we the
people actually do better in college and
life providing communication skills
interview skills research skills writing
literacy
all right so the team from Southwest
Tech came in fourth in last month's
state competition but congrats to all
who participate giving us hope for the
future we always want to know what's
cool it's cool you got something let us
know cool is cool under the Community
tab of our website or just email cool at
school at 8newsnow.com and those are
some really sharp young men and women I
mean like we were saying maybe there's
adults who aren't really sure what some
of the Constitution is about of course
these kids know yeah I know and
hopefully they'll never forget yeah
right yeah we need help I feel like the
things that you learn around that time
they just stick with you right like in
that and not just the facts but it's
also public speaking and working
cooperatively and learning to debate
instead of holler and argue that's that
collaboration yeah that's key now that
skill seems to be forgotten and go away
as you get older as we see in Congress